sa vie brut vous regardez déjà retourné
allez suivez moi
on va commencer ma scène préférée par
1,6 et moi et moi
la salle avec ado ça c'est un peu mon
endroit c'est des cadeaux que je ne sois
un peu personnellement prêts c'est là
qu'a fait ce sont pour se cacher allez
vous recensez c'est pas un truc du mois
ballack à faire là on a fêté des choses
peut-être des anniversaires
la ddc factuellement c'est un peu je la
touche à tout se passe c'est le bureau
dernier c'était aussi mon bureau voilà
c'est là où enfin tous les projets se
font est ce que des foules
faites le tour sans moi
c
les silences plateau s'il vous plaît à
leur moteur ça tourne au sens on peut
clapet s'il vous plaît c'est pas sa
tenue
parce que c'est écrit star comédien une
journée type sur 10% on arrive très très
tôt là ça fait un petit moment qu'on est
dans les studios d'aubervilliers donc
dans l' agence
donc on arrive on se fait maquiller on
se fait coiffer s'est habillé et ensuite
il ya un truc est assez drôle sur ce
tournage spécifiquement c'est qu'on a
affaire à deux réalisateurs
donc on peut passer de l'un à l'autre vu
que c'est pas tourné dans la continuité
elle peut dans la même journée tourner
un peu du 2 passes et aux quatre fers du
5 revenir on a donc effectivement il
faut quand même que dans nos têtes à
nous ce soit très clair sur le parcours
du personnage et que ce soit facon
fusant de se dire bon ok je me sens j'en
suis rue j'en suis où allah dans les
épisodes
donc oui il ya quand même il ya quand
même un être à être clairs sur toute
l'infrastructure du personal avec les
autres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque épisode de 10% à tourner en onze
jours ce qui est assez peu et anjou
voilà on doit trouver des astuces pour
tourner vite et bien sûr tous là par
exemple aujourd'hui on fait une journée
qui va représenter 7 minutes d'un des
épisodes de 7 minutes pour c'est
beaucoup ouais c'est énorme
d'habitude au cinéma onf et on va dire
quatre minutes utile par jour je suis
derrière le combo je supervise tout ça
c'est à dire que très souvent tourner à
deux caméras donc en fait je dois
vérifier deux écrans tout ce qu'elle se
tourne parallèlement et je dirigeais les
acteurs entre les prises c'est à dire ça
c'est bien ça on répète toujours avant
fait une répétition même avant que les
caméras soient placés pour que justement
et les cadreurs et tout ce qui est
lumière puisse mettre en place par
rapport à nos à ce que veut le
réalisateur est ce que les comédiens
proposent dans leur façon de bouger
pendant la séquence
ensuite le installe les lumières et les
cadres et après la presse et chant
rencontre chance si un syndicat moeurs
ou si on décide de faire une conséquence
bon bah on le roule met en place et
ensuite on y va l'aperçu les aperçoit
qui les aperçoit rendra dans le recul
qui vient se passer ici quoi ouais est
ce qu'on fait quand même un petit insert
sur des pilleurs il s'entraîne il nous
faut l'insa sur les films
[Musique]
soit restaurée en fait ici pour l'aider
contraste un peu ça fait avec eux [ __ ]
tu n en plafond un truc comme ça c'est
la nuque la dernière saison vous êtes
déjà nostalgique
non mais en fait là c'est enfin
aujourd'hui
moi par exemple c'est mon dernier jour
de deux studios
c'est à dire que
je vais avoir d'autres séquences à
tourner mais qui seront en extérieur
donc voilà ça va me faire forcément
bizarre ce soir de me dire que ce décor
je ne le connaîtrai plus puisque en plus
de ça il va être réellement détruits et
les meubles revendus sur la précédente
saison par exemple du fait que le décor
n'était pas déconstruit on espérait
forcément une saison suivante là on les
choses sont très claires